hoy vamos a hablar de la peligrosa banda
criminal venezolana el tren de aragua
que nació en el año 2000 durante la
construcción del ferrocarril de
venezuela cuando el sindicato de obreros
del proyecto y una oportunidad en el
mundo delictivo a través de los años ha
logrado alianzas con otros grupos
criminales en varios países de nuestra
región como por ejemplo chile perú y
colombia debido a la crisis en venezuela
y la migración de millones de
venezolanos los integrantes del tren de
aragua salieron de su territorio y se
establecieron en la frontera con
colombia y ecuador allí tomaron ventaja
en el negocio de tráfico de migrantes en
perú y chile amenazan con asesinatos y
extorsiones para controlar la
prostitución también extorsiones y bueno
una cantidad de cosas que ya vamos a
hablar con nuestro primer invitado del
día les louis que el abogado penalista y
profesor de criminología de la
universidad central de venezuela luis
muy buen día feliz mañana del jueves
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 le preguntó
por el alcance la fuerza de este tren de
aragua y dar un poco de contexto digamos
a nuestra audiencia internacional de
como
esta temida banda criminal
sí muchas gracias raúl muy bordea el
tren de aragua es la megabanda más
grande de venezuela en los últimos años
como tú has dicho se ha expandido a
varios países en latinoamérica donde
tiene mayor fuerza hoy en día es en
colombia sobre todo en el tramo
fronterizo entre el estado táchira y el
departamento del norte de santander
luego se expandieron hacia ecuador hacia
perú hacia chile brasil bolivia por lo
menos esos son los países donde está
confirmado la presencia de células de
esta peligrosa mega banda insular louis
también llama la atención en que esta
banda la lidera un preso que se
encuentra recluido en la cárcel de
tocorón a pareciera también que lo hace
con total impunidad al conocimiento
imagino si lo sabe ya toda la prensa y
varios países de la inteligencia de
varios países y también las autoridades
lo sabe el gobierno del presidente
nicolás maduro porque en este caso no se
toman represalias contra este líder de
esta banda del tren de aragua que pasa
dentro de las cárceles de venezuela
porque pues no digamos no se toman
medidas concretas concretas
sí correcto lo llamativo de esta
megabanda es que es liderada por un
preso como tú señalas te de nombre
héctor rubén force guerrero alias el
niño guerrero quien está detenido en la
cárcel de tocorón que queda allí en el
estado aragua y es bajo el liderato de
este delincuente que esta megabanda ha
crecido y se ha expandido a varios
estados de venezuela en principio y
luego a varios países latinoamericanos
yo creo raúl que hoy el tren de aragua
es la organización criminal de mayor
expansión en américa latina superando a
las maras centroamericanas al primer
comando de la capital o el comando
vermelho en brasil e inclusive también a
los cárteles mexicanos porque
estas son células importantes que se han
expandido a varios países y ciertamente
el crecimiento del tren de aragua que
está afectando américa latina tiene que
ver con el desastre carcelario en
venezuela el niño guerrero el líder de
esta megabanda es lo que acá se denomina
cumpran es decir un líder de una
pandilla delictiva que controla una
cárcel y que actúa con total impunidad
es sorprendente decir esto es quizás la
audiencia internacional no lo comprenda
bien pero en venezuela estos planes
tienen más poder que el director de la
cárcel tiene más poder que los militares
que custodian la cárcel solo que los que
dominan toda la vida dentro del recinto
carcelario y desde allí cometen delitos
y desde allí reina el terror
louis pero porque no los pueden parar
porque digamos esta persona este
criminal puede más que todo el poder de
un estado porque el gobierno central
digamos venezolano no se ocupa de esto
que ya está traspasando las fronteras de
su país
si evidentemente
la existencia de planes como el niño
guerrero
solo puede ocurrir con la complicidad de
muchísimos funcionarios del gobierno en
nicolás maduro no acá hay un ministerio
penitenciario que sabe muy bien cuál es
la realidad de la cárcel de tocorón y
del tren de aragua pero no hacen nada
acá hay las cárceles las custodian
funcionarios militares
también hay funcionarios de este
ministerio entonces tiene que haber una
gran complicidad de muchísimos
funcionarios para que pueda existir
delincuentes como el niño guerrero no se
puede esperar que esta banda siga
su expansión digamos por nuestra región
de américa latina y el caribe digamos
como como criminólogo como también
abogado penalista como como ve el futuro
de esta banda criminal si realmente
pudiera a lo mejor para darse no tanto
en venezuela como ya lo estamos hablando
pues que opera obviamente con impunidad
y complicidad de algunos funcionarios
obviamente penitenciarios se pudiera
parar digamos con una fuerza y con una
cooperación conjunta de varios gobiernos
en esta región a lo mejor como como de
chile de perú de colombia que si están
digamos con la mira puesta
el agua
raúl lo que hemos visto en los últimos
dos años es una expansión tremenda de
tren de aragua que ha ido pasando de
país en país los últimos dos países en
los que se sabe que tiene presencia en
bolivia y en chile entonces si vemos
todo este crecimiento en los últimos
años uno lo que podría pronosticar es
que siga el tren de aragua expandiéndose
hacia otros países latinoamericanos y
creciendo en los países donde ya tiene
vida una de las dificultades las
dificultades que han señalado las
autoridades de estos países
latinoamericanos donde tiene presencia
del tren de aragua es que es
prácticamente imposible la colaboración
con el gobierno a nicolás maduro para
identificar a los individuos que entra
en estos países para tratar de conocer
el prontuario criminal los modos
operandi etcétera no hay colaboración
entre el gobierno venezolano y las
policías de los países latinoamericanos
yo creo que una buena idea eso que tú
acaba de mencionar que vista la
dificultad de la participación del
estado venezolano en la lucha contra el
tren de aragua no estaría mal que
policías de latinoamérica se unan para
intercambiar información e intercambiar
estrategias para combatir a esta
megabanda